now let's get more on the news the
police in Portugal are understood to
suspect a foreign pedophile of being
involved in the disappearance of
Madeleine McCann Portuguese police are
said to have boosted their case squad
after information was passed on by
Scotland Yard I'm joined now by the
co-author of looking for Madeleine
Anthony summers Anthony thanks very much
for joining us on the program what more
have you heard about this potential new
suspect I know a little that I can't
talk about and because of these sources
and but I think what strikes me as
really remarkable even now struck us
when we were writing the book is the
multiplicity of DataFlex pedophiles in
the area of praia de Luz it's really
extraordinary looking back that the
police have so many suspects they have
suspects because they're already suspect
people who've been questioned about
other disappearances other assaults on
children um and I suppose in a way this
isn't some logic to that this is a part
of Portugal that is flooded with
children particularly British children
in in the summer months but still unless
you were into the story and you've
worked the case it's hard to imagine
that there could possibly be such a
number of pedophiles all in one area so
you've always believed have you that it
was a pedophile that was behind
Madeline's disappearance I think
rationally there are only three sensible
conclusions one is that she simply is a
little girl a very bright little girl
that she may have wandered out into the
night and had something awful had
befallen her the second that it was and
the police did consider this a great
length because there had been a lot of
burglaries in the place where she was
staying that there was a burglary that
went badly wrong and hampered in some
way as she was killed possibly because
of variables trying to keep her quiet
and
third and to me because of the number of
suspects and the evidence that the
apartment had been washed the strongest
suspicion was that a pedophile is in
both our Kron correspondent Martin Bruns
has said that there's a sense of renewed
optimism at Scotland Yard they've asked
for another 12 months money to fund
their investigation as opposed to asking
for just six months is that the sense
you get I think that's it that's
entirely rational there had been the
buzz going around that the investigation
was going to be wrapped up finally after
more than a ten million pounds and the
police would not be very welcome if they
said to the government we want just a
little more time and they've been
getting small amounts of money for a
matter of months at a time but this time
they have asked for a year and it's a
clear indication I think that whether
they're right or not they believe they
have something rather solid to go on and
how big is the investigation in terms of
the Portuguese police at the moment
that's harder to judge I think both
teams have been boosted with amount and
increased because of this new lead
do you think we'll ever finally know
what happens Madeleine I talked to a
Scotland Yard sauce some months ago we
said the policeman would you know
because that's not detectives the actor
out Rodarte of detectives that every
case is solvable in the end stay at it
long enough chip away at the information
available and you will get somewhere and
he said he thought this case was
eminently solvable I suspect that at the
moment the thinking it's got Minyard
certainly is that they have something
and that there is a possibility that
happily or I think more probably I'm
very unhappy the result will be unhappy
that they may find out the sense that
get a real sense of what happened and
the waiting goes on for Madeline's
parents of call
awful unthinkable unthinkable sentence
it must surely be a relief than whatever
the outcome but look one shouldn't look
just at the dark side the probability
that little Madeleine what now brother
grown up medellin 16 years old this year
and has gone i think is enormously
likely on the other hand 56 percent of
children who disappear in the united
states which is the only place where
there any statistics worthwhile 56
percent of them are found alive
eventually and that's something i'm sure
a talk that the McCanns must must
cherish